est-ce que le Français a vraiment une
hygiène douteuse
vous êtes vous êtes rare à la télévision
vous voir rarement sur les plateaux de
télévision on est dans d'autant plus
content et flatté que vous soyez là
Christine voilà merci je sais que vous
aimez pas les gens qui sont
impressionnés par vous vous dites ça me
met mal à l'aise alors je vais essayer
de pas être trop impressionné par vous
donc moi les gens me la laissent ça
m'impressionne on va pas s'en sortir
alors en fait je crois que vous n'êtes
pas du tout conscient de l'effet que
vous produisez vous dites les gens
fantasmes à cause de mes rôles ils
imaginent que j'ai une espèce de pouvoir
de séduction c'est archi faux
c'est très sympathique merci en fait
Christine se trouve pas belle mais si
elle le dit elle a peur de passer pour
quelqu'un qui aurait de la fausse
modestie donc c'est très compliqué
ça vous rend encore plus attachante et
plus belle
bien alors vous êtes ici pour le nouveau
film de Régis Barnier manthuman avec
Joseph Inès et nos deux amis pygmées que
nous avons reçu ici récemment et l'autre
comment il s'appelle
ça va passer
alors on va faire le pitch alors ça
commence en Afrique en 1870 un
anthropologue écossais Joseph Inès et
une redoutable chasseuse vous
capture un couple de pygmées et le
ramène à Édimbourg pour les étudier et
là les amis de l'anthropologue les amis
de Joseph finesse les considèrent ces
deux pygmées comme des animaux et les
exhibes dans des eaux lui au contraire
il les considère comme des êtres humains
et effectivement il s'attache à eux ils
commencent à communiquer avec eux et ils
découvrent une véritable humanité chez
eux c'est un très beau film c'est un
film assez universel contre le racisme
qui peut qui peut fonctionner partout
c'est un film où il y a on peut on peut
lire ce qu'on veut dans le film vous
allez le voir juste parce que c'est
c'est un film d'aventure et c'est un
film avec plein de choses nouveaux quand
on a dont on ne parle pas beaucoup au
cinéma
cette période là particulièrement de la
recherche des scientifiques sur
l'origine de l'homme
et c'est aussi une fille vraiment
d'action avec beaucoup de suspense
et des choses assez choquantes dans vous
êtes parfaite en femme de l'époque
victorienne en pleine jungle avec les
bottes le fusil enfin c'est très très
romantique et alors vous êtes tout seul
votre mari probablement été mangé par
des par des lions vous êtes obligé de
vous débrouiller pour survivre vous
savez que c'est pas bien d'exporter des
animaux sauvages mais vous le faites
c'est ça un peu le personnage non je
pense pense que je pense que c'est c'est
son métier d'exporter les animaux
sauvages elle a du mal à exporter les
humains elle se sent un peu coupable et
elle a vraiment c'est la seule qui a une
vraie connaissance de l'Afrique elle est
une vraie conscience aussi mais en fait
je trouve que ce personnage est
peut-être pire que les autres dans le
mesure où elle sait exactement ce
qu'elle est en train de faire mais elle
fait quand même
envie de faire pas mal d'argent et pour
pouvoir revenir dans son pays qui est
l'Afrique alors qu'une femme assez
moderne non oui je trouve un peu
féministe presque non et puis c'est une
période qui m'intéresse beaucoup cette
période là qui est vraiment le début du
féminisme avec les premiers femmes
étudiantes les premières femmes
qui avaient une éducation une vraie
éducation comme les garçons
alors chez vous les racines afro
victoriennes ne sont pas loin puisque le
grand-père de votre mère était ingénieur
et il avait traversé l'Afrique du Sud
avec sa famille dans une charrette à
beuh et le soir il dînait en smoking
c'est exactement ça dans le film
cet univers là
alors vous êtes né en Angleterre d'une
famille très chicout bah comme il faut
quand même comme il faut une famille
normale
alors votre vie ça commence comme un
roman votre père était pilote de chasse
il est mort quand vous aviez cinq ans
votre mère se remarie avec un autre
pilote de chasse qui meurt 6 ans après
c'est incroyable non
et très difficile pour elle et pour nous
les enfants c'était très difficile enfin
ça c'est des choses qu'on qui la brique
enfin des expériences comme ça c'est des
choses qui qui nous donne nos caractères
donc faut pas pleurer
vous avez commencé la comédie très tôt à
l'âge de 4 ans vous jouiez un berger
j'étais un berger un vieux berger en
effet avec une canne c'est pas un peu
tard quatre ans pour jouer un vieillard
mais là très vite vous êtes aperçu que
c'était là que vous étiez bien quoi
c'était quand vous étiez en
représentation j'aimais beaucoup me
déguiser et faire semblant d'être
quelqu'un d'autre et je continue
avec Régis varnie vous le faites très
bien d'ailleurs merci
alors votre famille vous décourage de
faire de la comédie parce que par sens
des convenances ça se faisait pas et
vous décidez de devenir professeur d'art
dramatique ce qui était une sans doute
une mauvaise idée oui
j'ai enfin je me suis inscrit dans un
dans une classe où on apprenait à être
professeur et je me suis vite aperçu que
c'était vraiment pas la bonne voie et
que pour faire ce que je voulais faire
il fallait que je quitte l'Angleterre et
que je recommence à nouveau quelque part
ailleurs et voilà et c'est là que la
France a hérité de Christine Scott
Thomas vous aviez 19 ans vous êtes venus
ici comme jeune fille au pair dans une
famille et c'est cette famille qui vous
encouragé à faire le métier d'actrice
et c'était à cause d'ailleurs et je me
souviens très bien j'avais tellement
peur d'aller au
concours de la rue Blanche que qu'elle
m'a mis elle-même dans elle a appelé un
taxi elle m'a mis
et donc vous êtes jamais reparti de
France mais ma maison chez moi
en médecine
aujourd'hui un grand médecin quelle
spécialité
c'est il est obstétricien
[Rires]
obstétrices tu vois c'est pas un mot
facile non plus
[Applaudissements]
et alors à cause d'eux à cause de ses
enfants donc vous n'avez pas fait de
carrière Hollywood c'est parce que j'ai
choisi de privilégier la vie française
la vie que je pouvais trouver ici avec
ma famille mes enfants plutôt que
cavaler là-bas et et avoir à faire des
choses
qui m'attirait plus tellement en fait je
suis allée je suis j'ai fait un tour et
puis je suis revenu
vous regrettez pas jamais si parfois
quand les enfants pleurent
si parfois on se dit Oh j'aurais dû
rester et puis on a plus de liberté ici
bizarrement
les femmes de mon âge dans le cinéma
américain c'est très très difficile et
là vous voyez les rôles que je viens de
jouer là uniquement en France avec
Arsène Lupin et puis manthuman et petit
coupure
c'est fantastique c'est fabuleux
oui j'ai eu une période méchante c'est
fini là j'ai plutôt dans les comédies
alors en préparant cette interview je me
suis rendu compte que c'est pas la
première fois que vous jouiez avec avec
des pygmées
en 86 vous avez fait under the cherry
Moon avec Prince
ça sentait la vannes
il est absolument mais ce film under the
cherry Moon vous l'avez pas mis dans
votre filmographie hein
je suis très fière de ce film c'était
mon premier film je jouais au théâtre
dans un champ en Bourgogne une pièce de
Marguerite Duras c'est tout d'un coup on
m'appelle pour me demander d'aller faire
des essais avec Prince qui était à
l'époque le Sorman
et puis je me suis trouvé dans une
limousine en allant à Nice j'avais
jamais essayé dans un hôtel de ma vie
dans ce cas là et là c'était les hôtels
4 étoiles c'était mignon quoi
alors vous êtes sans doute l'anglaise
qui connaît le mieux les Français
je crois qu'on est plusieurs à connaître
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors Christine est-ce que le français
fait tout le temps la gueule oui
[Musique]
voilà
et encore rappelons qu'elle ne prend pas
le métro
est-ce que le Français a vraiment une
hygiène douteuse
peut-être que non
est-ce que le français se croit vraiment
supérieur aux autres non
vous pensez que les Français
je me sens quand même adoptée et je me
suis adaptée
vous parlez beaucoup mieux le français
qu'elle tienne birkina est-ce que le
français vraiment nul en langue
étrangère
pas aussi mieux que les Anglais ou les
Américains est-ce que le français est
vraiment prêt à dénoncer son voisin si
on le lui demande oui ah est-ce que le
français arnaque vraiment les touristes
quand ils viennent en France ah ça je
sais pas parce que j'ai jamais été tout
récent en France
est-ce que le français
j'ai du mal à repérer les dragons en
fait
est-ce que le français passe vraiment
son temps à parler de sexe
est-ce que le français Ambroise bien
est-ce que le français fait bien l'amour
est-ce que le français est sympathique
n'en demande pas trop tirer
vous connaissez ça la carte la carte
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
il attendait
mais j'ai pas de voisin asseyez-vous
qu'est-ce que vous devez faire on va
changer les choses
est-ce que
merci
est-ce que ça vous va au moins moi ça
doit aller parce que j'ai des grands
pieds mais je ne sais pas si vous vous
allez pouvoir mettre un talon aussi
ça me va très bien très bien
passé c'est une pervers je tiens
inquiète et tout
ouais ça va non c'est bien passé tu veux
refaire la chaussure non c'est bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu